hey i'm marine wilson and i'm ross aslan
and reza what do you think happens when
we die i know what happens we become
part of the vital all-knowing all-seeing
essence of the universe
seriously no dude i have no idea i don't
know what i'm talking about
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
okay so seriously what what do you think
happens when we die rain
well
okay i'm sorry to give a boring answer
but i'm a member of a religious faith
i'm a member of the baha'i faith and i
pretty much ascribe to that now that my
faith doesn't give you any
concrete answers but i believe that the
divine essence part of myself moves on
past this material realm into
some other plane of existence that is
based far less on the ego and far more
on love and it's uh
uh moving into kingdoms ever approaching
the divine consciousness i know that
what does it look like though what is it
i mean what is it is it a place paisley
okay um
flowers
smells like honey chamomile rooibos tea
um i have no i have no idea i have no
idea you know i was fortunate to grow up
in uh in a belief system that doesn't
really believe in in heaven and hell so
i haven't had to wrestle with that
um you had to wrestle with heaven and
hell oh yeah no it was all about heaven
and hell and this is precisely why i
wanted to have as our guest uh on this
week's pod uh the great rob bell rob
bell has been a friend of mine for a
really long time um for people who are
unfamiliar with him he is a white
evangelical christian a former pastor in
fact he
founded a church called mars hill which
is to this day one of the largest
churches in america he he was a mega
church pastor that's who he was um and
he's young and he's cool and he like
plays music and he surfs and like you
know he's one of those like cool like
punk rock christian pastors you know
what i mean like the cool kids pastor
and then
in the midst of all this massive success
right people are writing articles about
him he's you know the face of mod
american christianity
he has a kind of a bit of a spiritual
breakdown himself because he starts
thinking about precisely what we're
saying right this idea of like
a heavenly reward or eternal punishment
and hell especially just doesn't make
any sense to him you know it
it it's so
is not an align with what he believes
god is
and and what god represents
that he starts to question it and those
questions become doubts and those doubts
become a very famous book he wrote
called love wins which basically says
hey i don't think there's a hell
and
what what how do you think people
responded i think that they probably
loved it i think they probably high five
they high-fived them and they hugged it
shifted the entire kind of theology of
evangelicalism uh what's the opposite of
that oh whatever the opposite is
what happened okay yeah
he was branded a blasphemer a heretic
the church that he himself founded
kicked him out that church is still
going but without him
um
and
he sort of became
this kind of heretic christian but
he would not give it up and to this day
now you know he's of course he's written
many many more books besides love wins
he wrote what we talk about when we talk
about god his most recent book is called
what is the bible
he hosts his own podcast called the rob
cast which is this weekly conversation
about faith and spirituality he travels
the world bringing this message of a
real christ-centered
evangelical believer's
quest but one that says
look this can't all be about
you know reward and punishment heaven or
hell and in doing so i think he's bigger
now than he ever was as as a pastor and
so when we wanted to talk about what
happens what happens after we die is
there a heaven is there a health who
better to go to than an evangelical who
surfs you had me at a pastor who surfs
rob bell welcome to the
[Music]
show my name is rob bell
i've been making things for a while
books
short films
events tours
and 2 000 broadcast episodes um
not that many but uh that's what i've
been doing for a while and i'm so glad
to be with you all and you've been
making uh kind of alternate christians
very happy
i never heard i've never heard that
phrase
that's a phrase you can use it it's
yours
is that a thing so ron bell you know
we're here to talk about uh life after
death heaven and hell and everything in
between okay
you are walking across riverside drive
right out front of this podcast studio
you get hit by a bus talk me through
what happens where do you go and what
happens to you
i'm so glad you asked me to speculate as
people have been doing for thousands of
years
my i would assume i'm not in my body
because i assume my body's in the middle
of the street yeah your body is so
whatever's happened i am disembodied yes
secondly
we now know
in a disembodied state
like from quantum physics you have
einstein who immediately who was the
first to be like hey wait
time is fairly bendy this past present
future is actually a construct
and that there's some sort of eternal
now that undergirds our conceptions of
time so i would assume that i am in some
way free
from this thing that we're all in right
now which puts everything in terms of
past present future so you think about
past regret future worry you think about
how much angst how many calories we burn
just
because of being split i'm here but i'm
not here this person they were talking
to me but i felt like they were
somewhere else i'll be with you in
spirit you think about how much so i
would assume i am in some level
free from that the best the best analogy
that i have heard of what you're
describing
is um a simple matter of perspective
right if you think of time as a line
that you are walking it's a road that
you're walking so you're in the present
the road in front of you is the future
the road behind you is the past now
imagine you suddenly sprout wings
and you fly 50 feet up yes you see the
entirety of the road at once
yes or an 18th century mathematician
named edwin abbott did a whole series of
images about think about your life like
a pen past present future like a linear
um but then what if you were to set the
pen down on a desk which is a flat plane
and that most of our conceptions of time
involve
like you think of a beginning middle
like a pencil or something but perhaps
time is more of a plane it could be an
orb i just want to say mine was better
right can we all agree this was better
than that stupid mathematician in the
middle ages
he's dead who knows where he is right
right okay so step one step one time
ceases to have
any kind of so let's
it's a little slower so great so you're
floating above the bus your body you're
disembodied all of a sudden your time is
like amorphous
like what are you rob gonna do because i
know like if it was me i'd be like oh
this is so cool before i like quote
unquote go anywhere or uh have some kind
of different plain kind of voice right i
want to like dabble around in this time
thing a little bit let's go visit me
when i was three and see what that was
like would our first impulse be like a
like a a reverence an awe just uh
or would our first reference be where
are the buttons
right where are the let's go play with
this because i immediately my dad's dad
died when he was eight
so my dad's dad was sort of a presence
and absence growing up and my dad's
brother died when he wasn't 16. so there
are these two
large figures in my life i've never met
but they're a presence and absence um in
the same way there can be somebody in
your life who's here but they're not
here right they're actually here bodily
yeah but you'd like a
uh sometimes a sibling or a co-worker i
feel that way about rain all the time
come on are you here rain are you having
i was gonna say my parents who are here
but not here so i have instant questions
like i like there are people
i have questions
for
yeah uh so there's so there's a lot on
the other quote unquote there's sort
reunion oh all the people who went
before you who are gone who left too
early you get to hug them and beautiful
music plays and tell me about
but there's also
no what was that about
because i lived with those decisions you
made or what was that thing that was in
the
dna bloodstream the family tree you know
what i mean i wonder how much
which leads me to the third point
i uh
i wonder how much
of what would be would most strike us
would be a sense of disclosure and revel
and revealing tell me more what do you
mean
that thing that happens when you see
what had been previously hidden
and suddenly it's brought out oh i see i
wonder if how much of a disembodied
post past present future involves
some disclosure of your own self
the way the world works
disclosure of your own stuff like
answering for your sins quote unquote
like some kind of like oh i think the
great mysteries at the heart of why we
do what we do um that period of my life
i kind of understand what was going in
play there
that relationship which to this day
when i think about it it was just funky
i know something else a friend of mine
his girlfriend just left him and he
knows
there's something else going on
but there he can't get anything out of
her but he's just no exploring all those
things i wonder
yeah i wonder how much of that
disclosure you see
your life you see i mean think about
therapy or psychedelic experiences how
often what it's uh
yeah
it's almost like the there's some sort
of veil that pulls a bit and you go oh
that was what was in play there i like i
like this idea that like i finally will
know um how many of my girlfriends
cheated on me and when
which leads me to a fourth
um i wonder
if
there is something in that state
that you are able to see
like right now if you find out how many
of your girlfriends are that will
involve
your heart your emotions your anxiety i
wonder if somehow you're able to see
with some lens of grace
or unconditional this is it just is
that you can see it
and it doesn't
amp up all of your stress levels you're
just able to go
okay i'm really glad that you brought
that up because what i really want to do
is actually slow this down even a little
bit more
[Music]
what you said is
first of all really fantastically
mind-blowing right time ceases to exist
but if time ceases to exist as a
as a linear experience right and it sort
of bends and curves in on itself then
you have a very good point which is that
the emotional investment that we have in
cause and effect
which is so much a part of how we
experience things how we define them um
how we react to them at a deep emotional
level
if cause and effect no longer apply then
i could see how those emotions don't
apply anymore that it's like oh yes i
can literally see my girlfriends
cheating on me but but because it
doesn't have a cause and effect aspect
to it i don't have the same emotional
response to it but i would go one step
further
and the question here becomes does that
spirit
the disembodied self yeah and i want to
actually go back even further and talk
about that
right because there's that right the you
know the ghost in the machine yeah the
the mind-body dualism and all that stuff
um
does that
spirit disembodied have
desire will intention personality well
how can it if
if ego is so attached to our animal
natures like i have
my wife and i have pigs we keep them in
the front yard they run around these
pigs have egos like they get they really
like to get their feelings hurt and they
want their cookies when they want it and
if you're eating and you don't share it
they make this noise like
why won't you share your food with me
like you you see these kind of like
animal ego stuff happening in these pigs
but if
in that moment of disembodiment i love
that word like what if kind of what we
know as freudian ego wants
desires base or needs uh something i
want something for myself
um and if those things evaporate and
what we're left with is some kind of
just divinity
um you're right then what what what
happens next in that process you're
floating above the bus without
driven kind of
process
hey folks has more time at home put you
in the mood for some upgrades perfect
timing because brooke lennon's biggest
sale of the year is coming this weekend
which means you can get your interior
refresh at some really great prices
brooklyn's comfort game is unmatched and
their lineup keeps getting better
five-star sheets were just the start
and their collection of cozy must-haves
now include everything from dreamy decor
to their newly launched slippers i
didn't know they had slippers they got
slippers reza you know ryan you know
this about me the only reason i do this
podcast is for the free stuff sure but i
use my brooklyn in sheets all the time
i've got them on my bed right now
they're they're fantastic i took a pair
of scissors i cut up the brook linen
sheets and i fashioned them into
under undergarments which i'm currently
wearing under my garments okay well
that's why they're called underground
i'm going to marry my brooklyn in sheets
i'm going to have a family with my
brooklyn sheets folks listen don't miss
out brooklyn's biggest sale of the year
starts this weekend
listening after the sale well you know
what you can still save visit
brooklyn.com and use promo code
milkshake
for twenty dollars off with a minimum
purchase of a hundred dollars that's
brooke lennon
n e b-r-o-o-k-l-i-n-e-n dot com promo
code milkshake
hey rayne uh
you may remember a very very long long
time ago when you weren't rich and
famous right i can't even remember that
i know it's hard to remember but there
was a time when you actually cared about
your checking balance and you cared
about overdraft feasts dude i got killed
on overdraft fees all through my 30s and
40s frankly ah if only you had chime
back then chime is this award-winning
app it's also a debit card it has saved
its members more than 10 billion in
overdraft fees with spot me fee free
overdraft eligible members can overdraft
up to 200 on debit card purchases and
cash withdrawals with absolutely no fees
folks you deserve to have financial
peace of mind so join the millions of
americans already loving chime sign up
takes only two minutes and doesn't
affect your credit score get started
today you can go to chime dot com slash
milkshake that's chime c-h-i-m-e dot com
slash milkshake and then this is the
part where we read really really fast go
rain banking services provided by and
debit card issued by the bancorp bank or
stride bank n a members fdic spot me
eligibility requirements apply overdraft
only applies to debit card purchases and
cash withdrawals limits start at twenty
dollars and may be increased up to two
hundred dollars by chime chime member
overdraft fee savings based on eligible
members use of spot me versus 33 average
overdraft fee overdraft fee data based
on bank rate checking account survey and
crl june 2020 overdraft fees report
well what's interesting in the jewish
into the jesus tradition you always have
it always comes back this idea of a new
heaven a new earth a reconciliation of
body soul spirit everything being put
back together right partly because it
never has its landing point point as
disembodied yeah because the landing
point is always integration
so body is good
soil sexy sweaty all the stuff pigs
is all central to the experience yeah
and from a psychological perspective by
the way it's important to understand
that
the notion of bodily resurrection which
as you rightly say it has such a deep um
religious and theological backing behind
it has everything to do with the fact
that
we as human beings are incapable
of conscious awareness of disembodied
experience like we we are our bodies and
so it's only natural that if we think
about
um
post-life we think about it
in our bodies yeah right so okay that's
why but that's not how we think about it
if i when i leave here and get hit by
the bus
and yeah and if i were to speculate i
assume my body's in the street right
and
i would speculate that i'm
i'm not bound by it like i was okay
previously right like when you're in a
room with somebody who's dying yes
that
sense that they are
here but not here
they're like taking their
last breaths
but the thing that made them them isn't
in the room right anymore so i just had
a number of those experiences in my
early years as a pastor where i was like
their bodies right here
and yet something is leaving has left is
um
so i don't know what that is or how that
gets reconciled or even where they
went or and as a pastor i saw stuff that
was so
strange people laying there in the bed
uh i remember my first job
uh there was a woman who her family
gathered around the hospital bed
she's taking her last few breaths and
then having not been communicative at
all sits up in the bed looks up above
their heads sort of at the ceiling opens
up her arms smiles
and then lays back down
and takes her last breath so i don't
even know where you put yeah any of that
stuff yeah yeah i'm just going to keep
adding the disclaimer of the mystery of
all of the speculation
i just saw such odd stuff about
uh essence might be a word
soul
um my favorite phrase is um vital
essence
oh there you go because it's not
anachronistic soul is such a new idea
but the belief
that we are more than our physical
bodies yeah that predates homo sapiens
we we find that belief system in
neanderthals we have found that belief
system
in the evidence that we have collected
from
uh cro-magnons so before homo sapiens
existed belief in
right
let's just use the word soul and
all agreeing that the word soul is just
a word something that's real but i can't
hold up my hand like i can hold things
that are real i'm gonna blow you i'm
gonna blow your mind a little bit more
here justin barrett
uh a very brilliant cognitive um
psychologist that used to teach at
fuller actually not too far from here
he has done an enormous amount of
research on concepts of the soul
what he does is he takes kids usually
like i think under five or something
like that
and he has surveyed children from every
part of the world children who have
grown up in religious households
children who have grown up in atheist
households uh you know
like i said from all corners every
culture
and what he has found is near unanimity
in the belief in what is referred to in
psychological terms as substance dualism
the belief that the the body
and the mind and you can replace the
word mind with soul you can replace it
with vital essence you can call it prana
you can call it buddha nature you can
call it chi you can call it whatever you
want to call it the other thing that is
us the chad you can call it chat
um
that the body and mind are separate and
distinct it is a belief that we are born
with in other words it is a belief that
you need to unlearn
so
there's an enormous amount of
conversation right now in cognitive
science about why like why are we born
with this belief but there is no debate
that we are born with this belief
the theory that uh
sort of comes closest to making sense
is a theory that's developed by a man
whose name i've completely forgotten but
anyway the theory is is this because we
are
consciously incapable
of
imagining
lack of consciousness
we
have necessarily developed a mechanism
that
keeps us from even considering lack of
consciousness that the idea of
that
there can be a moment in which we cease
to exist
that concept is impossible for the
material mind
to envision and so therefore the
material mind
necessarily creates
this idea of a vital essence that
continues
it's okay it's a pretty good theory it's
you know it's unprovable i mean maybe
it's i would but isn't it isn't it just
as simple as like when i'm a kid i can
feel myself like in my body sweating my
shoulder hurts i have a mosquito bite on
my elbow and i can be thinking about
something else and i can have a feeling
and i can be humming a song and i just
have a different experience in the world
of my consciousness than i have in the
world of my body it's it's related i can
feel it literally related to my body but
not just of my body necessarily there's
a there there's a dialect there's like a
back and forth between these are two
different things and they are somehow
integrated
we're having this conversation so we
could each right now
uh observe ourselves having this
conversation
but then there is
uh
the me that could observe me having this
conversation yeah and then there is the
me observing me observing the observer
observing the observer however far i
stepped back there's always some sense
that there's some part of me that could
step back and observe that so in some
ways the human experience has been
there's something about me that can
infinitely step back
among the many reasons why
belief in the soul is universal
let's add to those many reasons because
there's a soul
you know what i'm saying you're just out
and saying it let's just you know fine
i'm not i'm not saying i know there's a
soul i'm just saying if
one of the reasons is because we're
incapable of consciously uh conceiving
of unconsciousness or if the other
reason is well because because of of our
uh ability to envision ourselves blah
blah blah engaging ourselves envisioning
ourselves sure sure okay also maybe
there's a soul
yeah absolutely and then you think about
uh someone sold an old soul
which was a way of saying um
or there is something about their vital
essence
that is slightly
uh ahead
above their this is a 13 year old kid
but the kid just said to me we all walk
with a limp don't wait or something
you're like wait wait wait okay there's
something
about
there's something about this kid in
which their physical
bodily thing
and what appears to be their vital
essence don't aren't a perfect match
right they seem to be or you think about
the soul singer
and the soul singer
gives expression to some thing that we
all go
i know resonate oh yeah so this this
woman is singing an old slave spiritual
which is not
an ex and yet i know what she's talking
about something within me feels a
solidarity that cuts across
uh
socio-political economic everything it's
just there's something she's
articulating that is a universal human
experience that cuts across the whole
thing we have all these ways
to articulate this sense of there's
something present
[Music]
okay so yeah so you're now you're pure
substance
no form vital essence your vital essence
you're looking down at your flattened
body i still my body is in the street i
just have to keep coming back to it i
have a body in the body in the street
you you're instantly aware of every
[ __ ] who was cheated on you
and you and you don't care we've talked
about that you're like yeah you know
okay uh you care but your care takes
place within some larger right context
scope yeah okay now what now let's move
forward god
see
just making a guy speculate
it's just grinds against do it this goes
totally against
uh first off
i think there's uh
there's a paradox between knowing and
unknowing that never goes away so
sometimes when people talk about when
you die then you know everything which
to me parentheses boredom
so
uh words like exploration come to mind
because there's so much to each of us
our family tree alone
fascinating all of the sliding doors of
i could have gone this way it could have
gone that way sure life went that way
all of the random
weird things that happened in the car
hit that car and then you were late for
the thing but if that car hadn't come
and that and so all the chain of events
so there's endless things you could
explore about your own instant knowledge
yeah so i there's instant
endless exploration you could do but i
would assume it also takes place within
vast unknowing
oh think about science we just got a
whole new sphere we just we just had our
first picture on the front page of new
york times couple months ago of the
first black hole black hole yeah so what
our experience here in these bodies not
disembodied is that every
thing every explanation merely moves the
mystery down a layer at some level now
we have a picture of a black hole done
no
now we have a picture of a black hole so
there's something about the experience
here where every time we learn a new
thing genome mapping et cetera
now we have a whole new set of questions
and those scientists go out and get
grants because it opened up yeah what
about dark matter and dark energy right
come on what's that 96 percent of the
universe is dark matter and dark energy
and what we know is that four percent of
the universe is known matter but what we
also are told in the same breath is by
the way that 96 is somehow necessary an
integral for this universe to be a
universe
well that's
that's an answer yeah but it immediately
does a whole other thing so my
assumption is that there's something
kicking in like that
so i'm really fascinated by
what you're talking about in this idea
of
knowledge awareness the sort of sense of
mystery
but it it does have to me again this
kind of
uh elemental problem which is
i tend to associate those things with
desire
with will
and indeed with personality yeah like in
other words absolutely right
i'm a i'm a curious individual like if
you told me oh in instant after death i
will
be outside of time and space and will
have access to all knowledge reza
aslan's like woohoo that's like i that's
awesome i want to know all of that yes
but did you hear what i just said i said
i want i want yeah well you said i first
of all i said i and then you said
and i said want so let's bear down on
those two things and dear listeners no
we did not ingest a bunch of pot
brownies before this conversation
they haven't they haven't hit yet um
number one
is that thing an i
number two
does that thing have
desire or personality or or anything um
i think so i think that's central to
being
i think that's central to being who you
are
uh
okay
desire
it sounds like you're using it with a
like a negative thing
but there's also the sense in which your
desires have been good for the world
so i wonder at some level do they become
reconciled
um because that's what we all want we
have this
will and energy and fire within us and
almost the path to maturity
this side of the getting hit by the bus
is somehow
learning how
to direct those fires to focus that to
harness that to
turn that i want into what's interesting
something good for the world not the
constant battle of i want a bunch of
stuff that's going to con crush me and
right yeah so we have higher wants and
basis yeah right right okay this is
fascinating because you you are very
much saying
that that vital essence
is the core of who you are outside of
this meat bag that it that yeah sits in
and so maybe not desire in the way that
you that you're talking about it though
i will just kind of remind everybody
that the buddha said that all desire is
the source of suffering whether you're
desiring something good or something bad
just the very notion of wanting is the
source of all suffering but he's
definitely where all the fun is wouldn't
you want to do that
the buddhists are all just not very fun
at all
so rain have you heard about this thing
story worth it's uh it's this online
service it helps you and your loved ones
preserve precious memories and the
stories that they have for years to come
it's like this thoughtful meaningful
gift that connects you to those who
matter most i just got this from my
mother-in-law this is how it works
every week story worth emails your
relative or friend uh or in my case your
mother-in-law uh it sends them uh some
kind of thought-provoking question you
know and you get to choose the question
too there's a whole vast pool of
possible options but then each of these
unique prompts asks some kind of
question that you yourself never thought
to ask questions like what's the bravest
thing you've ever done in your life or
if you could see into the future what
would you want to find out and then
after a year story worth compiles all of
your loved ones stories including photos
into like this beautiful keepsake book
that you'll be able to share and revisit
for generations to come it's like a mini
documentary of a person of their of
their memories and who they are their
thoughts their their stories what a
fantastic gift idea i'm going to
absolutely dig into this uh for my
stepdad with story worth i'm giving
those people that i love the most a
thoughtful personal gift from the heart
and i'm preserving their memories and
stories for years to come if you're
looking for a great gift for that loved
one
story worth is the place to go and we
got a deal for you go to storyworth.com
milkshake and you'll save 10 bucks on
your first purchase i did that's exactly
what i did that's storyworth.com
milkshake and you'll get 10 bucks off
your first purchase your loved one will
thank you for it storyworth.com
milkshake hey folks good health starts
with good habits and quip makes it easy
by delivering all the oral care
essentials you need to care for your
mouth
the quip electric toothbrush is loved by
over 7 million mouths now wait is that
one toothbrush that was used by seven
million mouths or does that mean it was
seven million toothbrushes it has timed
sonic vibrations with 30 second pulses
to guide a dentist recommended two
minute clean already on top of your
brushing you can upgrade your quip with
a new smart motor to track and improve
your brushing with the free quip app and
you can even earn amazing rewards like
free refills products target gift cards
and more so beyond the brush
quip has everything you need to build a
complete routine with stylish and
affordable electric brushes starting at
just 25 you won't be paying through the
teeth hell for better oral care
if you go to get quip dot com slash
milkshake right now
you'll get your first refill free that's
your first refill free at get quip dot
com slash milkshake that's spelled g-e-t
q-u-i-p dot com slash milkshake
quip the good habits company
okay continue we're we're an instant
past now
i i think you are in possession of a
profound recollection and remembrance of
who you were
30 seconds earlier before you got hit by
the bus
i i think the unique the uniqueness
of reza
is
surprisingly intact
memory
uh imagination
uh passion
i would assume that these things are
still with you at some level rain do you
believe that
yeah i do i do i think
uh if it's a vital essence
here's in the baha'i uh tradition and
i've brought this up before there's a
really beautiful metaphor it's only a
metaphor it's not reality that metaphor
is you're a baby in the womb you're in a
reality you're alive right and you're
having experiences you're not having
cognitive experiences necessarily but
you're developing your fingernails and
your nose and your eyebrows and your
elbows that you will need in the next
world you have no idea why you're
developing those things while you're in
the womb and while you're in that state
that's one plane of existence you move
from that plane through a very traumatic
birth you're pushed through a little
hole you come out you're crying you're
covered in goo and you come out into
another plane of existence and at that
point you're not able then to kind of
uh dream up something like the internet
you're just a you're you're a baby
you're you're you're maybe you're right
right
you're still half from that womb world
right so here we are in this world in
the baha'i tradition we're developing
our spiritual qualities in this world
for use
in some other plane of existence so
patience kindness humility compassion
whatever how whatever kind of qualities
of the divine that you want to
ascribe we're trying to develop here we
don't know exactly why we're developing
them here but we have to admit it is
kind of a perfect cauldron or anvil to
be
developing humility and compassion and
patience and stuff like that and then
we're going to take those with us uh to
the next plane or realm or what have you
and maybe this is just my own
attachment to my sense of self but the
idea that somehow when i die that my
vital essence then becomes just a drop
in an ocean and i lose my individuality
and that nothing i've experienced here
um over planet earth over however many
decades
comes with me or matters or just
disappears memories experiences
i can't get with that because it just
doesn't it doesn't make any sense to me
i mean i have a very limited
consciousness but it doesn't make any
sense what's then the purpose of this
i'm gonna go if there's a soul then
there's some kind of creator and what's
the purpose of this of this experience
this weird petri dish of pain called
planet earth and humanity and you know
uh
if we just die and forget it all and
lose our individual individuality and
lose our consciousness and just enter
into some kind of buddha state we become
light you know i i don't get it why even
have it there i think that there is an
endless dance between the hole and the
part between the individual and the
larger unity you see that now so uh
particles gather together and form atoms
atoms was it 300 000 years in the life
of the universe atoms begin to bond with
other atoms you begin to see molecules
molecules bond you get cells so what we
see the whole thing has been unfolding
for billions of years is these parts
that make up holes
and if you lose any sense of the
individualness of the parts you lose
something but if you lose their
belonging to the whole you lose
something
so there's something good about an
individual there's something good about
these uniqueness there's something good
about these parts that make
the whole i would say this is i think
maybe the second fork in the road
in all this right the first work in the
road is riverside drive
yes the first fork in the road is
am i just a meat puppet or is there a
vital essence right right you get hit by
the bus and it's all over it's dark and
that's the end of it and we've come to
the assumption there's a vital right
okay so one second we made a left the
second fork in the road is does that
vital essence carry
any trace of your self ego personality
whatever whatever makes you you yeah
and rob and i are arguing
very yes yeah and i
am not so
sure my problem is this
i'm with you rob and i love the way that
you described it because i to me it is
it is uh deeply grounded in what little
we understand about the nature of
reality the foundation of the laws
of science are as we'd already kind of
danced around the conservation of energy
and matter the belief that everything
that exists today
has always existed and will always exist
as long as the universe exists that
means that when you get hit by the bus
it ain't over like not i don't mean
theologically it ain't over i mean
science in terms of matter it ain't over
in terms of matter and energy it may be
shaping form or exactly a particular
shape but it's a transfer not an
elimination difference it's a
transference not an elimination that's
the first rule of science so let's start
there
so okay so maybe the matter transfers in
some way but there's also energy right
the energy also transfers and so if i
were to say what is that vital essence
that's now looking down outside of time
and space at the body on the ground an
instant later i would say that that must
be pure energy but
does it make sense to think i mean does
it make logical rational sense to think
that that
um transference of energy carries with
it even an echo of the personality which
after all was a result of a lifetime of
experience but answer my question then
what's the point of all of this i don't
know i i don't know if if all of a
sudden right or a ball of energy without
any memory or any attachment to the
resinous view or the rainness of me
then
what what's the why happen i literally
don't know i don't know i don't know um
it's interesting in string theory they
now say that for the universe to exist
as is there must be at least 11
dimensions right so uh height width
depth maybe time is a half dimension
maybe we're like a three and a half or
four right but you have with a straight
face now scientists saying actually for
this thing to be what it is we're gonna
have to have more dimensions which now i
will just say string theory is utter
nonsense and [ __ ] and it's so funny
like when you really start to like
people people take string theory
scientists take string theory so
seriously and then when you ask them to
explain where they came from tiny
vibrating strings yeah they're like uh i
don't know the same same way that i came
up with the fact that jesus is king like
it's literally there's no evidence to
what you are saying you're vibrating
straight and holding everything together
yeah connecting things just a way to
make sense of things that don't make
sense but anyway keep going yes even the
floating above looking down on the
street
something about the human experience
like for thousands of years uh appeasing
the spirits of the ancestors communing
with the dead the communion of the
saints the
i'll be with you in spirit although i
can't be
something within us has some sense that
our body
is something happening within the larger
phenomenon of who we are so almost like
this
whatever freedom and joy and kids and
love and all of the greatness of this
life we still have a regular witnessing
to something about its cramped
something within us feels like
we could push these walls i mean how
many how many videos on mtv when we were
growing up at the end of the video the
walls
are all open and the band is playing in
a big open field
[Music]
oh man this is this is so good i don't
want to stop we we can't stop we can't
stop there's there's way more to say
here reza we need to make this a
two-parter okay let's do it this guy's
brilliant um we haven't uh dear listener
even gotten into some of the meat of the
stuff that we want to dig into i've been
wanting to talk to rob like let's get to
jesus where does jesus play into all of
this it's great okay there's physics and
metaphysics and string theory and
consciousness and stuff like that but
how do you rectify this than in a
christian worldview so uh i think
a little bird told me we're gonna get to
some of that juicy stuff in the second
half of the conversation
dear listeners as you know we always end
these conversations by reminding you to
uh go to apple podcasts or wherever you
listen to podcasts and and uh rate and
subscribe and also leave a comment and
in the comment section ask your life's
big question and who knows we might
bring you on the show and and you can
ask us in person and here with us today
is a gentleman
from ontario canada who has literally
the most canadian name
i have ever heard in my entire life kurt
smiley kurt smiley are there guys
is the name
you would give
to a canadian on a sketch show i could
think of more canadian names what about
like um
gordon maple do you know a gordon maple
curt i do not unfortunately but i wish i
did with that name curt it's great to
have you uh on the show so uh you had a
you had a really fascinating question
it's a question on a topic that uh that
rayne and i often chew on uh hit us hit
us with it okay so my question for you
guys is with the invention of instagram
and all of our
social media have humans
developed an innate fear of being wrong
and or learning from our past and
mistakes see that's a solid question
right there that's a deep one i mean i
guess russell let me let me follow that
with a follow-up question you're you're
good at this one were humans ever good
at being wrong
does the social media just amplify an
inherent human trait or is there
something special about it has it
unlocked
some
uh enormous human character defect that
was hitherto un unexposed see i i would
say a little bit of both remember when
we were kids
and we would do something wrong and
people would talk about how that's going
to go on your permanent record
like you if you if you do this it'll go
on your permanent record and it was
funny because there was no such thing as
a permanent record
and now there is
it's called social media it's your
permanent [ __ ] record
right i mean i've made
i've made jokes as you know rain on
social media that
seemed jokes that seemed i don't know
funny and somewhat appropriate at the
time and i look back on it now and i
think
maybe not so funny and not so
appropriate but too bad because it's
there for eternity that's right i was
actually at the center of a social media
[ __ ] storm
i made what i now consider to be a
rashly gross and insensitive joke about
rape
and i said if i was ever raped i would
want it to be to a whole lot of love by
led zeppelin
and
i could see that not working
that didn't work it didn't go over very
well of course all the bros and dudes
loved it but anyways there was a
shitstorm there was this front page of
the papers and usa today and yahoo and
there were articles written about rain
wilson makes tasteless rape joke but
what it was was that joke was right at
the cusp at the end of when rape jokes
were acceptable because there was a long
period of time in fact if you watch
sitcoms you can watch like friends and
other sitcoms and they make rape jokes
repeatedly because comedy writers make a
lot of rape jokes and i'm in comedy
writer rooms and they're making rape
shows doesn't mean it's okay that's just
the way it was but it was like my tweet
was the cusp at which
from then on
not okay to make it and i completely
understand why one doesn't make it it's
it's such a prevalent
uh social uh
horrendous thing that has happened to so
many women and it's not something to
take lightly at all
but it's interesting how there was this
kind of cultural shift and my tweet was
right at the center maybe i'm just being
narcissistic but it really was
that you can kind of say before the rape
joke and after the rape joke kind of was
uh
kind of hinged on my tweet here's my
point about the whole uh
permanent record thing and why i brought
it up
is that
you know we all we all have
thoughts and ideas that uh jokes that
seem
right in the moment and then later on
we're like well that wasn't very right
but you know
what you shared them with a handful of
people big deal they probably forgot
about it anyway there's no need for you
to like go to those four people and say
hey remember how two weeks ago
i thought that uh you know
whatever that
that uh
help me with a joke rain i don't i don't
have a joke there i thought that uh uh
feces hats jokes were funny yes and i'm
gonna apologize to those three people i
said that too because i don't feel that
that's the case anymore i was wrong i
made a mistake you don't need to do that
but when you post it
to you know hundreds of thousands of
people or in reign's case millions of
people
and then you realize maybe you were
wrong or that was
you know poor wording or whatever
you have to admit
to millions of people
that you were wrong you can't just like
let it slide you know what i mean yeah
yeah so there is something to this i
mean
yeah in the early days of twitter no one
really thought about it being on your
permanent record we just thought like oh
this ten thousand people follow me and
these are my fans and friends and we're
just gonna kind of like tweet [ __ ] at
each other and talk shop and and give
each other [ __ ] and
and that's that we didn't know that
years later people would be sifting
through them looking and saying this is
this is what this personal person
officially thinks and feels for the rest
of time
um we just in the early days of twitter
we didn't think of it that way but i
guess
my point is that um
there are certain human tendencies that
have always been there
the tendency of the kind of lynch mob
with the torches saying burn burn this
person
and then the tendencies of you know
gossiping and backbiting
um
the
and then the anonymity of social media
and the rapidity of social media um has
exacerbated these worst
our worst human tendencies
and um
and and that's and that's what has
caused uh
this inferno the thing about twitter
and and this is it took me a while to
learn this
lesson is that not everybody needs to
know every thought that goes through
your head at any given moment yes okay
yep um sometimes just keep that [ __ ] to
yourself
and
the thing about twitter is that it
invites you to just kind of broadcast
that every thought
without you know without really thinking
about it and and
but it comes with consequences right
whereas
before social media that like i say
there wasn't really that many
consequences i mean okay so you offended
two or three people you just go and
apologize to those two or three people
and also by the way speaking about
apologizing on social media at least on
twitter what that usually means is
deleting the tweet which is way worse
way worse i find
right like no matter what awful thing i
said
i would much rather deal with the
consequences of it
than
delete it and then have to deal with the
consequences of having deleted it it's
like right you know to your pitchfork
analogy it's like walking out and being
like i'm the witch come and get me you
know you said the word broadcast and
that made me think there are a couple of
things that social media fool us into
believing
one is that we have friends
because we get likes and thumbs up and
friends and followers
they're not our friends no they're not
our followers they're not close to us
they don't necessarily like us or love
us or care about us in the slightest
they're not friends okay
and
it feels sometimes like a conversation
it feels like you can have a
conversation but it's not a conversation
a conversation is sitting across from
someone eye to eye breathing in the same
room listening and responding that's a
conversation it is a broadcast so it's
broadcast broadcast broadcast broadcast
broadcast broadcast that's not talking
it's not conversation it fools you into
thinking this conversation it fools you
into thinking that they're your friends
but they are neither so it's um
it is the supreme uh illusion of modern
humanity listen kurt thanks for the
great question uh and everyone thanks
for your wonderful feedback please leave
us a positive review on apple podcast
with your life's big question and maybe
we'll bring you on the show just like we
did with kurt kurt go argonauts thank
you
cheers guys very much appreciate you
guys have a great afternoon folks if you
want to be like
and join us here you could uh
certainly go and and rate and review ask
us your life's big question you can also
find us on social at reza aslan and
rayne wilson we are on twitter at
metamilkpodcast
and on instagram at metaphysical
milkshake let us know your last big
question we just might explore them on a
future episode you never know
that's right and uh make sure to tune in
next week for part two of this
scintillating conversation we're gonna
get to the juicy meaty jesus of it all
to be continued
[Music]
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson
it is produced by safa samazadeh yazd
harris lane mick dimaria hashem himself
and dj lubel
cast media is the production and
distribution partner it is edited by
tyler newbold
it was additionally executive produced
by goal reese lucina and daryush
rizwella no thaft it was produced by amy
s choi and rebecca lehrer of the mashup
americans associate producers are
jocelyn gonzalez lindsey crowderwill
sarah pellegrini mary phillips sandy and
shelby sandlin
[Music]
[Music]
don't you want to have podcasts in the
next world you know
we can continue this conversation from a
different perspective as long as there
aren't 30 episodes of it but yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you